c'était tel que c'est que tu as fait
savoir pourquoi tu l'as tuée je savoir
accepter les avoirs du fait qu'ils
viennent
qu'est ce que tu as fait envie jacques
godin était un géant du cinéma de la
télévision et du théâtre
il nous en a mis plein la vue avec sa
voix sa présence et ses rôles marquants
ils savent que nous sommes ici j'ai vu
des rois qui retournait son contenant né
à montréal jacques donnay obtient son
premier succès populaire en 1957 dans
l'émission de télévision aura dix ans
puis les grands rôles s'enchaînent à la
télévision de radio canada dans les
années 60 il crève l'écran dans 7e nord
débat et du poulet pendant cette période
faste
il joue entre autres le rôle du costaud
beef dans le télé théâtre la mort d'un
commis voyageur ne lève pas encombrant
je vais peut-être me nourris de votre
tête me cacher quelque chose
jacques godin s'investissent et
entièrement dans ses personnages au
point de ne faire qu'un avec eux en 1971
son interprétation de lenny dans des
souris et des hommes a marqué les
esprits n'enveloppe nakache d'un cirque
à karachi en 60 ans de carrière et brad
gaudet a joué dans 240 production et
s'il était omniprésent à la télévision
qu'on le voyait au théâtre au moins une
fois par année au grand écran son rôle
dans l'adaptation cinématographique de
la pièce bien at war with claude fait
encore écoles je ne suis que je n'aurais
premier temps de regarder quévy atlas
est pris avec une guide on s'amuse
égorgé le monde et si dans les années 90
il a eu une place de choix à la
télévision ces dernières années jean
gaudet se faisaient plus discrets sud en
2010 avec le film la dernière fugue de
léa pool
il faisait en quelque sorte ses adieux
au cinéma
[Applaudissements]
maintes fois récompensé tout au long de
sa carrière jacques goddet et peut-être
un humaniste ce qui a eu le feu sacré
pour son métier jusqu'à la tombée du
rideau l'enfer martin il faire souffrir
réseau ici louis fait depuis mai
radio-canada mauriac
[Applaudissements]